Now, let's continue and cover some key terminology with.
data structures
in Python we have
four primitive data structures
You can of course use classes to create your own
data structures, but on python there are four for you to
get started with.
They are lists.
We have two poles.
such and number four dictionaries
Let's begin with lists and cover some key terminology.
So a list is a collection of
elements
and what element has a special meeting?
So say you have a
sequence of prices
One thing 100 200 450 just some
random values.
Put the between square brackets and you have credit yourself
based.
We call the elements of a list.
the members of a list
elements
and let's assign this list a well. Let's
assign
this entire list to a variable. We'll call this prices.
Okay.
An element has two.
properties one of them is
we can see around in front of us in the other one is implied.
So we have something called key and value.
And we have a special type of key. Okay, so
just quick quick terminology. We have something called
an element.
Which is a member of some sort of data structure.
And in every element we have every element has two
characteristics. There's something called key and value and the
special type of key called index.
A key is how you're able
to retrieve the value of an element.
But if the keys are arranged in a certain way you can
oh well if they are numbered and linear.
and in
incremented by one we call that special type of key and
and index
let's look at examples of both keys and keys and indices.
So what are the what are the indices? What are the keys of?
these four elements well
This one is zero.
This one is one two and three, of
course in programming. We always count from zero.
All right.
So this entire thing is the limit element.
Okay, we cannot see the keys when
we have a list.
but
that is implied.
Every element is associated with a key. And
now when your keys are in this form that where
they begin with zero and they go and increments of what we call those keys indices.
Okay, so they're not exactly interchangeable.
And how do we access a particular element?
of a list
well, we type in the variable that is
refreshing to that list open a pair of square brackets and
then
type in the corresponding key for that
element. So if you want to print 450
Or let's say you want to know what is the last price on this list? You would
type in the corresponding key, which is three.
easy enough, right